he puts his life on the line okay he
loved he puts his life on the line yeah
he puts his life on it and I'll tell you
one thing he didn't do you take your own
advice
wow what a good question that's a good
good question
do I ever take my own advice yes I
actually do only as of late I lived a
long time not taking my advice time a
lot the time I felt like I don't know
like I felt like a bit of a waste I used
to make it not of excuses for myself
this is only in this one area yeah but
when I was a PT obviously people would
come to me and be like literally how
kind of his way to happen I do this do
that yeah I mean what the advice is
always the same mm-hmm and I make I used
to play like it's easy obviously even
when it's just simple things like eat
healthier yeah like obvious I wouldn't
say that but like the specifics of what
it was wouldn't aren't much of an
adjustment to your life yeah and even
something as small as I cut an out just
couch sugar don't need any sugar yeah
for the next two weeks don't need any
bread for the next two weeks just try
those few things alderney any dairy for
next few weeks and there you'll be
surprised yeah I bore what happens these
times I would not be satisfied with my
body and I'm not willing to do that yeah
and they're coming to me like a
chocolate bar and all this stuff and I'm
a prophet you could make it one [ __ ]
week by these times I'm heading straight
to the shell garage for a monster on a
mars bar
[Laughter]
that's so funny [ __ ] away the time and
sometimes I would practice what I preach
but like other times I'll be doing
mounting telling these man to fix up
their lives yeah
but as of late 100% I practice what I
preach I take my own advice is yeah it's
imperative man because yeah more time
that I'm given a device nowadays is too
you with trying to improve the quality
of someone's life
yeah by taking their life in their own
hands kind of thing and I have no choice
but to do that yeah because otherwise
I'll die depressed yeah so yeah and
that's the air that's the only advice I
give Freddie so yeah - blow by you as of
late I would say like you said before I
am a lot more now well when I back in
the day obviously I feel like I never
used to I feel like I'm a person that I
can talk to you anyone and try and solve
their problem kind of yeah I just like
to if I if I know all the information I
feel I can give you good advice to
either go in this direction or go in
that direction like how many do we have
to do kind of thing and especially when
it comes to like I like listen to girls
problem is when it comes to
relationships because I think I don't
you - I don't think emotionally when it
comes - yeah I think logically is the
emotional plays a huge buy relationships
but I just think logically obviously I
live with a girl so it's easier for me
to have this kind of conversations
because those conversations just come to
me yeah yeah yeah but I feel like until
you've been put in that situation that
they describe in it's so hard to just do
X or Y yeah that's the thing like I
would say I say all the time like when
people around me up like for example
like if you lost your temper or
something yeah it's so easy for me to be
like bro just relax
yeah what's wrong with you like come on
and try and calm me down and so easy
yeah you're right when you don't have an
emotional investment in something yeah
it's so easy to give a logical solution
course and I remember when I when I was
a PT I was working for that PT company
for a few years and I always used to
have issues with something yeah there
will be some kind of of issue and I
would be I couldn't couldn't think like
what's the best way around this I in my
head on my by there's no way around this
like is either this or is this there's
no middle ground
yeah and I'll be fuming or I'll be
stressed out so I would text the owners
of the company and I'm gonna write this
at the issue I'm happy having and
they're like oh yeah that's fine just do
this this and this and this and I always
used to say like how do you come up with
such OnPoint
answers
just or the drop of a hat yeah and I
can't I'm sitting here for hours and I
can't figure out they're like bro trust
me when you have an emotional investment
in something you cannot think logically
yeah it's cuz I don't give a [ __ ] I can
give you logical answers and I yes you
do feel like even though I take my own
advice yeah I actually do feel like just
as you said it's so easy to just say do
X Y and Zed yeah because you don't have
the invertible investment but if you
were feeding exactly how as emotional as
they were yeah like you it's not you
know it's not easy to just do that just
to do that oh boy it's tough them ones
are very tough because I feel like as of
late now I am slowly taking my own
advice but only more so when I feel like
oh [ __ ] I'm actually in the predicament
where I gave someone else that advice
yeah I taught him to do x y&z so maybe I
should just do I said exactly nah me yes
and it's a hard pill to swallow because
as it is so easy to dish out but it
seems you're in a predicament for like
[ __ ] I know I have to do but I'm so
annoyed I want to do that that's the
thing and you'd like to give yourself
the people like to give themselves
justifications as to why their situation
is different yeah yeah no one likes to
think that they're the same as someone
else they want to think that their
situation is unique yeah because they
have the emotional investment like no
one feels as emotional as I do like no
one's dealing with this level of stress
as I am and yeah turns out of everyone's
the [ __ ] inside everyone it was exactly
a perfect example of literally being the
same I was watching and I said I
mentioned it earlier but I tell you
about what it was his documentary on
Netflix called three identical twins two
identical twins three identical
strangers three identical strangers yeah
and based on such a dope tile from
basically was the story that happened
like that hey know before they've
there's 70s I want to say yeah No No
maybe seventies early eighties yeah
we're basically even spoiler ella is
about to come but everyone should still
watch it because the like obviously I
never yes or no I can give you that
overlay but the the minutiae the details
and there are key basically the story is
this is like the premise the premise of
Elia is that
there's kid yeah in 17 you know 18 years
old 18 19 yeah and he's just got he's
got his first day at college so he's
driving down to college different state
different see everything yeah in America
driving down to college rocks up to the
college and everyone is is [ __ ]
high-fiving him spotted him hugging him
everything a lot cool hi hi hi hi hi hi
hi um everyone's waving at my hi hi hi
any speaking with a fight everyone's so
friendly here that what's going on yeah
and then like one thing comes up and
lips it lips is him and says I'm so glad
you guys you came back and he was like
what the [ __ ] is going on coward on
walkie and went to his dorm and one
guy's walking past his dorm spots him
looks back and says no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way and he's like what and
he's like random I know you don't know
me or whatever but when you were born
where you adopted and he was like yes I
was adopted how did you know that and it
was like when is your birthday like July
12th 1986 and he's like yes yes it
[ __ ] is like how do you know that
and he's like big man I don't know if
you know this you have a twin brother
you've got to him brother and is I would
you meaning is like my best friend from
last year is your twin brother he looks
exactly like you and I know you're not
him as soon as I saw you I knew you and
him because he told me from the from the
summer he's not coming back and I spoke
to him like yesterday and I know he's
not coming back so I know you're not him
but you have a twin brother and he was
like what what they ran to the phone box
bailed my man I said I think I'm into
him brother he gave him his address they
drove to his house it was his twin rova
they'd never met they're both living in
two adopted houses they'd never met
before it's a series or a documentary or
it's a documentary on Netflix is a
documentary documentary it's a true
story true story
and watch it is tomorrow so he goes in
there meets his twin brother is mad they
call a rapport
says like what's going on is like you're
never gonna believe this but basically I
met my brother for the first time
yesterday we didn't know existed are
like adopted parents didn't know each
other sister this is crazy that we were
obviously separated at Birth so they
were not Wow
so report comes down doesn't how article
on them yeah takes their picture puts it
in the paper the next day wondering it
looks at the paper no [ __ ] way
it goes to his Bridgman of work and
sister Zelda like familiar mine said he
looked a was him there was two of him on
the paper and he was like what the [ __ ]
these twins are me he rang one of their
adopted moms whose number was in the
paper whatever and said big man my name
is such-and-such
I live about half an hour for me 45
minutes in New York I think I'm the
third set of these twins I think I'm
with triplets because these men are kids
act let me rocked up they were all
adopted all separated at Birth all sent
to three completely different homes and
after the whole thing I realized that it
was a social experiment to see if like
it never ended in question like nature
versus nurture to see how they could be
grown up in different comp three
completely different homes yeah and if
even though they were separate and
didn't know anything about each other
were still the same kind of people
yeah so was their brain maha just not
even based on their experiences
completely based on genetics and fam man
basically said and what I already tell
you one finding there were interviewing
one of the triplets one day and he's
like he's over deed like downsides of
being like a triplet of being with your
brothers and stuff or discovering your
brothers and he was like to be honest
the only downside is is that it's made
me realize that I've met every unique
thought I thought I ever had
isn't unique because but all three all
three of us have had the same idea and
he's on about imaginary unique things
now pops into his head I thought oh this
would be cool or maybe I should do this
or like I'm interested in being like a
restaurateur I'm interested in this
sounds out there weren't unique ideas
both of his other brothers had the exact
same thought and it didn't matter ways
lived through doesn't matter who's been
through he's the interests are all the
same what how he episodes or it was one
thing I'm pretty sure was one long thing
oh really
now what's the whole thing yeah a 1-1
long documentary I've not even heard of
this mmm its new I know it like a few
days ago definitely watching it tomorrow
hmm
I love drawing juries that was sick and
I was like wow yeah just to show where
everyone's the [ __ ] same [ __ ] hope
you put it the same they like to think
everyone else I think they individual
but everyone has that's why [ __ ] is like
that's why this [ __ ] podcast is for
me
yeah or relatable whatever you want to
go as we say [ __ ] that everyone else
goes through yeah we're all the [ __ ]
same you all think they say about
different lives but we don't move the
same fundamentally we're the same like
to the core we're the same yeah just
like when you'd look at like I heard the
[ __ ] zebras yeah you'd think they're
all the same yeah they literally the
same that's how another being would look
at awesome like this man all the same
crazy that's crazy
you know our own heads we think we're
different it's not scruff it's literally
not [ __ ] as soon when you were saying
that story about the 303 my have I hide
that screw strangers I was painting the
picture in my head and it was sounding
crazy
it was sounding crazy is Gracie oh I'm
definitely watch it is crazy good proof
is good
it's a think that was a real story real
[ __ ] story huh but yeah man
that's really good I'm definitely watch
that whatever well somehow much recently
the tiger King I was really funny not
funny but like it was good watch it kick
was a good one his name Joe that's a
really good watch Joe eggs like he's
crazy he's a crazy person he is crazy
but I feel like he's sometimes he's
crazy was warranted but like there was
some extent that weren't were like he
took it to an extreme extreme but some
of these rants were warranted in my
opinion bro he's he's literally a crazy
person Carol Baskin is crazy she's the
like the face
she makes when she talks about her
husband that disappeared bro scare me
they scare me cuz she's it
she's a silent killer Oh rags rights
100% what she means my husband
disappeared and the [ __ ] murderer
five years and the day after five years
and one babe a clip they declared him
dead because it was after five easy
today someone dead I didn't miss it
five years on one day she declared him
dead and took all his assets and gave
the actual family took the other family
ten percent yeah she's a [ __ ] she's a
[ __ ] she is a silent piece of [ __ ] nah
that's you that I fear someone like that
more than Joey I was gonna say Joey
Essex Joey was like yeah he the reason
he scares me is because he's literally a
predator for man but it's Amanda brother
cheeks yeah he's a predator jinx man is
looking for meth heads he wants methods
that he can supply method to so much and
they were allowing him so much that they
will marry him when they're straight
there straight men who marry suckin [ __ ]
not even just a man enjoy exotic of all
people of all P they wouldn't a suck a
[ __ ] Joey exotic the tiger king for some
meth uh do you know uh do you know when
I felt sorry for him I think was an
episode one where he said he realized
from young he was gay and then he he
said he told he's dad and then he said
his dad took him to his mom and they
shook hands and agree that my son would
never come to my funeral
Wow I don't if you don't remember that
when I was watching it I was napping in
and out yeah he said you took his hadn't
agreed that the father said oh I would
never I never want my son to come to my
funeral and he said that day he packed
his stuff drove his car and drove off a
bridge he drove off for a PhD he was
said he was in braces for five years and
then then he moved state when he when he
was embraced for five years he met
someone somewhere like during that five
years thin that had an endangered cat
like a small a small cat and then that's
why it's not final slide bro old man as
he came out to he's dead so if he had
imagined he's and spoke to his bad
is that accepted him as who he was yeah
he would never be no talking he'll be no
Tiger King yeah bro
crazy is so crazy series of events like
that like blow my mind you think of the
back trustus backs that's his backstory
yeah bro and did you know it's like when
he married
he's like Travis and the other guy he
took their surnames he knows that I
didn't know if he's an original surnames
like Schreiber Grover or something
alright
and so he's there is he got a WI he's
got to know Doug because that's the
first guy and it's got a second guy so
right if you guys are watched Tiger King
you should watch it it's really it's a
really good series on Netflix I love I
love a documentary so if you can that's
a good point if you guys have any
documentaries that you feel like are
worth my while I've range the kind of
documentaries i watch i watch them all i
love him hit me up or hit us up on the
comments or likes or whatever and just
let me know what what's a good watch in
yemen some documentaries i i love ya but
some i just find so [ __ ] boring
documentary were like a diamond doesn't
for me good good one in a few that I've
got when I get into it but I'm deep yeah
I'm deep
I've seen the pharmacist now you told me
to watch that that's a good documentary
that's a good documentary I think that's
about the live episodes what is it but
the the drugs and kids and stuff yeah uh
what uh what this guy's done oh he's
crazy so the premise of it is obviously
he's a pharmacist he works in the
pharmacy and one night he is a son they
are comfortable where they live but
there's a good side and as a bad side of
town a karma where in America that it's
in America where is that they live but
the bad side of town is known as like
the black town and where there's a lot
of drugs and crack cocaine and stuff
like that so the police knock on the
guys door when he's come home and say
and said oh we found your son in x y&z
in a bad part of town
and he's been shot and obviously they're
they're like frantic away visa okay
Oh what was he and we'll go
see him as like no like ma'am he's dead
and they're just like what what what was
he doing there but I blah
they spoke the night before enemies and
I think he the son had told the parents
are he's going to so-and-so's house for
something a Harmon and they would like
to stay away about but he went up a side
of town to get drugs and I see in the in
that side of town white people don't
really don't really go so when he drove
through there I was asking everyone
asking everyone asking it [ __ ] for any
eyewitnesses black this is Sun legend I
mean no one was as you know as awesome
but then he said one of the things he
did was he went through you know the
yellow pages that you've got here mmm
echoes what everyone's numbers in he
said he ranked 50 people a day in the
area come on see the police got involved
in everything and ran fifty people a day
or something steeper like that in that
area and just as he was about to give up
he rang the last number on there and I
wish when she picked up he said Oh
finally you called me so if there was an
eyewitness that's all everything that's
how it is that's where everything and I
was think that lots of episode one well
that's just episode when it gets so deep
because they obviously they find out who
the killer was
but that's only in episode two innocent
because he then is now thinking why is
there such a high because he noticed as
well there's such a high demand for know
there's a lot of kids dying hmm relative
a fifteen like that twenty and
twenty-five age a lot of kids down but
know anything about it but then he
notices because he's a pharmacist he
knows so many people are coming in to
get a high dosage of one thing hmm by me
she starts to find his sauce and any
checks on the records who is prescribing
these and he finds the doctor and he
goes and looks at where this doctors and
we're stuck this doctor's practice is he
goes there during the day is locked he's
like that's a bit weird
he goes there at night foot hmm full and
I'll stop there brav there's a
documentary that sounds um that is even
sound like a documentary
sounds like a that sounds like her
oscar-winning movie um it's
I'll stop there it said it's a
documentary bro Jesus he puts his life
on the line okay he loved he puts his
life on the line yeah he puts his life
on it and I'll tell you one thing he
didn't find out I didn't get justice for
his son's death until a year and a half
afterwards Jesus and do you know crazy
thing was I was when I was watching I
think I was saying to Bella when I was
watching it that out why he's why he's
all this time he's trying to find out
what happened to be son he's not
grieving what's keeping a motive n he's
trying to find his killer and as soon as
he found the killer
the man [ __ ] grieved and right now
nothing left now I found the killer what
now and then alright then then that's
how the whole pharmacy thinks that way
he found out a lot of people are going
for this specific drug and then he finds
done found out afterwards yeah
so so he spoke to that Minister cetera
cetera cetera they all found the killer
the whole case closed that was done and
then oh wow denne evolves into another
thing they sue a company at the end oh
wow Oh bro isn't it's Matt yeah one of
our nurses is Matt I want to watch I get
so invested in bro so the way when I'm
watching a very good doc I'm [ __ ] in I
love documen I come in
oh my god there's um speaking of this is
kind of like a documentary it
technically kind of is but when I said
to you about the Dave Chappelle winning
the Mark Twain prize yes yes yes I know
it's just like a me thing yeah that was
one of the best documented not any one
of the best experiences of my life what
why they explained because so to context
it for people so Dave Chappelle won last
year won the Mark Twain prize which is
like the highest honor a comedian can
get in America anyway as the biggest
accolade someone can have in comedy in
comedy so when he is just like how do I
explain it how do I explain it so it
represent it was just like the visual
representation of everything like I hope
they're yeah
and the platform that they sent me that
was in like my favorite comedian of all
time yeah back of all time yeah and the
whole time I've watched him up until his
because before he started doing these
big big Netflix things from my
perspective for him growing up he didn't
quite make it because everyone in his
like era like Eddie Murphy's a little
bit before him it says Donna but like
Chris Rock Chris Rock Chris Sacca
they've all like in my clouded mind
they've all blown up they blew up
they'll do a movie yeah yeah had like
Chappelle's Show and stuff like that and
it was in a few movies even if he moves
you near so from that like Martin
Lawrence and all these people like there
I'm healing up yeah and he's down here
yeah and then I was watching his
comedies all along and I thought he's
the funniest guy I've ever seen way that
I story story today is unbelievable some
parallel to you and then like it's one
of those things that like you see it and
you go for it and they're like wow why
doesn't this guy get the rate is that
here he deserves like I think he's
amazing and like obviously the people
I'm talking to the school like no one
else in school at my age when you're a
young teenager is looking at like cuz it
was even old when I was a kid this is
bad he's like Def Jam Starbucks from
like the early 2000s look like the late
nineties yeah so no one even watches
those kind of things like no one watches
full-length stand-up comedy specials
like he's done so and I was just
watching Bear at him yeah and I had the
DVDs and I had like YouTube and just
watch all of them and I brought I
thought he was the funniest [ __ ] guy
yeah and I didn't see any of his
stand-up from like mid-2000s I didn't
see any of this Dallas for years and
years and years until his Netflix
special came out last year and yet the
double-barrel those first one was in
2017 um a couple years ago anyway so he
had the double barrel yeah that was on
the same one in it yeah and then he had
another one last year last year about
two years ago he's done three now yeah
he's done three came out last year I
promise you now the one the sticks and
stones one six is 10k my last year but
yeah he's had four before six and stones
here - W - W yeah yeah sorry had to
doubled oh yeah 2017-2018 thousand eight
and then then sticks and cloves two
thousand ninety here yeah so until
they're two thousand seventeen one I
hadn't seen anything of his since like
2005 here 2006 so I think you bar Dave
Chappelle's I couldn't seem yeah and
then he's been gone like all my life for
so many years yeah and he's come back in
and it's almost like a rush of
realization that it feels like everyone
knew about him all along
yeah so he's come back and I'm hearing
like Drake's dropping bars like they
paid me for you know just for to like
I'm sure pearl yeah like I'm hearing
that right Dave like Drake's talking
balls but Dave Chappelle sick and then
I'm hearing I got paid with this money
just to do his thing and then like it's
such a blow up on Netflix yeah people
asking me if I've seen it and I was a
rock
I didn't even people think people [ __ ]
with their Chappell like there and then
he's just drop him more and more and
more and more as all come to a head just
for me again to look on Netflix
coincidentally via cuz I didn't even
know he won the prize yeah I didn't
really even know what the pride of water
yeah I heard of it I didn't know what it
was um and then he just popped up the
other day out of nowhere when I'm just
laying in bed and just seen it I was
like what the [ __ ] is this clicked on it
and it's just hearing that the whole
world knew yeah and I don't did they
know people like the comedic community
hold him to equally as high regard as I
have my entire life and just in terms of
like you when I said about the video
before the Chris D'Elia fan yeah he's
like watching his [ __ ] is like and doing
his own ting has inspired me to to do
stand-up myself and I'm so happy I got
the chance to actually tell him today
that he means so much to me like Dave
Chappelle was like a big whatever I
think about anything that we talk about
on here yeah in terms of like what you
just said laugh at his storytelling like
I'm obsessed with storytelling and then
just being intelligent and being his the
the the thought process that goes into
his dress the way he
she's a sentence idiot different yeah
yeah and he's so perfectly structured
that makes it the most funny it could
possibly be
do you know I'm saying does that make
sense yeah it does because I've got a
specific joke that represents that so
well sometimes I was watching it's funny
with you talk about Dave Chappelle now
because I always watch in his a comment
which one I think was like the
equilibrium they acquit equality and
whatever one at 2017 whatever and he
talks about the four times he met OJ
Simpson that one yes yeah it's not that
one it's the one after well before our
Carmen but anyway he talks about a movie
that he said he meets up what he meets a
a t he's an easy nur like an award show
whatever and he meets a gay director and
he says I've heard you got loads of
movies like movie ideas and he's like
yeah man I sure I've got loads is that
pitch me one on the spot then he's like
oh so he's superhero movie and he's like
I'm not interested but it's like I was
at Hanoi sag a see-through movie mmm he
said the catches he rapes to save but he
saves more than he rapes where he has to
rape to save bro and then but that was
like in the middle of like his whole
sketch and then towards the end he
starts to talk about Bill Cosby about
how Bill Cosby to him was an icon
because there's so much he's done in his
younger lifetime that has made certain
people I he kind of paved the way for
them yeah yeah comedians and lifestyles
and stuff and apparently it was he said
that apparently that Bill Cosby was the
one that paid for Martin Luther King's
on screen money taught him to have that
I have a dream state yeah things like
that
Wow yes crazy a lot crazy but then he
said Bill Cosby has raped 54 people and
I thought to myself he's raped more
people than I've had sex with
and then the final joke was where do you
get it yay rapes more than he says what
he says so he it's spoken about raping
and like a a [ __ ] film like halfway
through the joke part of every sketch
yeah yeah
or that Bill Cosby Figaro who thinks
like this fantastic he's like he's
pretty is he's creativity this mindset
it's just there's a film right that
relates to this perfectly he's a film
about Mozart okay it's called Amadeus
okay and it's from God it must be from
like the 60s or 70s okay I watched you
when I was a kid is not my dad one of my
dad's movies it's one of the best meals
I've ever seen and it's about Moton it's
about him moving so most German right he
moves to Italy yeah to pursue
composition being like a music composer
so he's out there and he's the that dawn
like he's the new hot guy yeah so he's
running around doing eating this is when
classical music was everything and then
he just run in the tank yeah and then
there's a lawyer what they called a
royal composer his name was a guy called
Italian guy called Salieri okay and then
he's like the [ __ ] in Italy until my
talk comes through and just left
shutting it down and then um motor
starts doing his thing and then Salieri
feel is like how do I explain it
the whole film is about how Salieri is
the only person everyone loves Mozart
yeah but Salieri at that time was the
only person because he was a composer
yeah he was the only person who could
truly understand how amazing Mozart was
and he was not getting the credit that
he deserved for it because he was like
his unbearable how good it is like he
was breaking his heart and you said he
was one seen way he like gets on his
knees and his cursing God and his crying
and he says like this pervert line I'm
butchering it but it's like how I like
how can you be so cruel as to give me
not enough talent to be everything I
want to be but just enough talent to
acknowledge who is mmm I've heard that
line somewhere a common web I've heard
that before
bro yeah one of the best things I've
ever heard yeah and that's how I used to
feel about Dave Chappelle mmm even still
now
is that like how can you how can you yet
how can you like give me just enough
talent so that I understand this stand
because just how [ __ ] good someone is
yeah at everything that they do but
never give me enough like the way he
thinks about [ __ ]
it's just like he will say a sentence
that's not funny but be able to make it
funny
and he says like he was talking about
everyday about me about the Care Bear
joke yeah and there she man they said
the way he said it like he's said like
it used to be the Care Bears and they
like they just care about love and
affection and everything I hate anyone
that was mean and they were so
affectionate that man said literally
like these [ __ ] would shoot literal
love how and the way he said that
sentence was just like no one else would
be able to say that and just get like
design that scent yeah and the whole
story was just such a basic story but he
managed to make it hilarious I knew when
he tells the story he literally brings
you you're in there if I'm you're in the
room and you're like run in this story
like I can't hear anything else and he's
just talking about the [ __ ] Care
Bears and I said when they will get
angry they're common together and
they're shoot love are the chest and I
was like they but I grew up believing I
could do that yeah and anything that was
hard in my life I would just have to
stare it down and I'll shoot love on my
chest and then like just as everyone's
like deep deep deep into it like rah
this is deep man says broad turns out we
can't she love out of our chest and they
like but if you actually broken up
without right you're right like the
world is dark I'm and said but I have
short love on this chest and I'm like
you're amazing and just in all of that
he's like people the people the stories
people are telling about him yeah you're
just like he is too easy for him like
he's just it's not even like his hero
his stories and good expect to hear that
like right this guy does nothing but sit
in his room and write jokes he does
nothing but research he does nothing but
practice and all this stuff but all
you're hearing is he's just that rocking
up to
College storms like looking for weed and
then like Sarah Silverman sees it comes
home he come all the way to my house
smoke to join and just did yes said Aziz
Ansari said they were just banging out
magic mushrooms and like he was talking
about when his boy was talking about he
when he pitched the weed movie randomly
rang him like if you're the first I'll
call you telling we're doing a [ __ ]
weed movie together and he's not what we
move mustard don't worry about it locked
off the thing Universal called him you
didn't we'd move from my mind yeah we're
doing a weird movie to give a cool bit
can you pitch it he's like yeah thirty
days is that cool city he hollered in my
day twenty nine my family you haven't
called me we need to go on his weed
movie matter what we banned you like how
can this guy be such a kid and he's so
unbelievably brilliant always those
funny and then just bro just watching
that whole thing I was just so Wow
fair enough wow that's amazing to me
there's a sigh yeah of course obviously
to you because you like you said he is
comedy to you he's he's literally comedy
and not everyone understands his comedy
but his comedy is intelligent comedy oh
yeah yeah way says everything
instructors every joke is so intelligent
it's amazing he's a funny guy mom it's
amazing so funny funny line I never
appreciate him when I was younger like
the Chappelle shows I've seen stumble I
can't sit here and say I've watched
every single episode the bait ones like
the Rick James [ __ ] James the KKK was
I've seen like you know mmm or heard of
the classic ones but I'm not seeing
everything bro and I feel like if I've
watched it now if I watch it now rather
I wouldn't have that same yeah yeah
would have enjoyed it yeah back in yeah
yeah bro it was ahead of his time yeah
it was amazing and everyone thinks he's
so sick it's crazy it's crazy that he
turned on 50 million today we turn down
50 mil to do another season turn down 15
millas it for 10 years now my soul Oh
bro he's a guy don't see so much going
through your head to do that I don't see
we'll never know why he declined in
that [ __ ] but you gotta be a serious
kind of character to turn down money
money makes people crazy money makes
people crazy like and like little things
like I remember I remember watching
I remember watching what the [ __ ] was I
even gonna say listen no not watching
listening
there's obviously from years ago I
wouldn't listen to podcast yeah a lot of
the podcast I've listened to I've
listened to them come from nothing okay
pretty much nothing yeah and work their
way all the way up to where I'm watching
them now listening to now and the
obviously making cash yeah and they live
in lavish but they were making off their
our back yeah and you hear all of them
say like you're gonna get offers from
this person that person to do this and
to do that with your podcast and trust
me it's gonna be the worst thing you
ever do like if you're smart turn down
the money short term and trust me you'll
make the money money like long time yeah
and then the whole time I'll just be no
rags that's what I'm gonna stay true my
guns are gonna listen to these man this
is what I'm gonna do but as time goes on
and we actually get closer on that
journey that actually happened yeah you
sell yourself I'm not gonna I'm gonna
stay true but when someone actually
physically says I will give you more
money than you've ever earned to do this
now no build up thing yeah like you're
not gonna go from earning 200 a month to
five hundred thousand a month to ten
thousand a month yeah like I will give
you 100 bags and now to do this thing
turn it down is impossible is him it is
it does it's a hard thing to do bro it's
a whole I mean now I know like you say
it takes all the human nature things
yeah more right now that's such a hard
thing to do mom and like you can't see
like when you're broke a hundred like a
hundred grand a year and a million grand
a year basically the same thing
Amelia got a million pounds a year yeah
100 grand a year and a million pounds
erh the saying if you're broke you're
broke so when someone takes you from the
enterprise and say bro I'll give you a
hundred grand a year now or you could be
an you're behind 100 grand a year for
the next ten years yeah oh I think I can
give you nothing now but you're
definitely gonna be only five mill or a
mill in the next five years what do you
do you take though I'll take the money
now because then I'll be thinking bro
100 and here yeah I don't care about
having a million year I don't give a
[ __ ] about that but where do you been
earning a hundred grand for ten years
then you know bro I need I need a
million a hundred grand I can't be
[ __ ] because you're like that would it
change bro and then you go Dave
Chappelle getting offers fifty million
and it's turning that that's it now best
before he knew what fifty million was
obviously he was making money money yeah
but he were making fifty million money
no one is there's no one is a man said
now I'm good you that's a character firm
that's off just to do a little character
and after all that man was telling when
he was telling the story mm-hmm about
the half act he was up he was gone for
12 years after you turn down my money
yeah he didn't no more swimming for 12
years yeah the fact that like he's now
come back and he's making he's winning
awards yeah he's making money yeah he's
made like at least 40 mil I think he
made up to like 70 this like this past
one but he's been making hundreds over
100 million yeah over the last couple
years - and he was still saying like you
think rod this guy did the right thing
it's all sick you is easy to see like
the quick overview of what has happened
but when he was in the communist or
explaining like bro I was going for 12
years
I thought everyone forgot about me man
said I thought I'd fallen off like I was
drinking I saw his pears
yeah and he's just turned down 50 [ __ ]
million dollars and he's seen everyone
come up in here and going nowhere
like he's done he in his head he's I bro
I'm done I [ __ ] it I was away from 50
million and I've got nothing to show for
it I'm [ __ ] like I've got nothing here
like everyone's leaving me in the dust
like I'm never gonna make that money
like I'm never gonna make 50 million and
now I'm definitely not gonna [ __ ] make
it like a [ __ ] it yeah a mansard
that's from 12 years yeah how long that
is 12 years is insanely long because
none of them I've known you yeah to sit
in that mindset yeah and then come back
and be a bigger phenomenon than you ever
were ever well mind-blowing to me
mind-blowing patience does patience
that's fine else fun Wow
he's creativity must have kept him sane
hmm because I don't know mom different
breed half different breed that is tough
boy that is tough what a character as a
person what a character he is he's one
of the greats he definitely is one of
the greats 100%
I think he's unbelievable he is he
really I can't wait for his that cuz he
said at the end of that he wants to be
at least three more we same with one of
his best friend's son he must need three
more sketches yeah at least three more
sketches so hopefully you got one he's a
dope guy man XD I presume
sick right come on y'all so let's go for
it see what we got
don't I didn't even check for them let's
see where we go yeah while he's looking
for a mighty awesome guys follow us on
instagram follow us and follow us on
patreon
follow us on Facebook shit's and gigs is
the handle for everything obviously the
podcast is chasing geeks underscore
podcast on the Instagram
find us on YouTube hit the subscribe
button and let's get this party going
one seriously follow us into our man
let's interact I want to interact with
more of you guys and so does he we just
want a laugh man especially through the
times all going through do you not just
want to laugh sometimes
tick tock is they as well let's have
some human interaction you feel because
let's talk about let's talk tell me
where you're from you go on now if I'm a
man this has come up with
she's going foodies I am going I ain't
got one man have you ever been into
having you've actually been in a
situation where you like am I the
[ __ ] yeah
am I the ask I've been in millions of
them I thought I feel like obviously yes
I hope I'm going on off the dome no put
me on the spot they're not mmm
[ __ ] dragonfly I don't know cuz I
don't know it looks hench [ __ ] you love
us I've I definitely fought a few times
like I might [ __ ] like no one ever
considers himself a bad person oh of
course not so when you see people doing
bad [ __ ] intentionally you're just like
that doesn't make sense to me and yeah
there's some things you can you can't
even ask him either so you just obvious
what but there's been times where like
how do I say lying is a big one okay
there's been times where like I see no
one like you just said earlier like what
I said earlier the other episode when I
said when sometimes if I cannot be
bothered to deal with something yeah I
will lie so when I said like doing he
said about the co-worker the social
worker well who's he said was ugly times
well she's banging like sometimes you
ever think like I'm lying for this
person's best interest but I definitely
shouldn't be lying yeah and then you
just do it anyway and then you just like
now [ __ ] you I should have like yeah
lines a weird one because like I don't
know way before in terms of our being
like ignorance being bliss based like
why is it that people think that like
that why is it that you think lion has a
weird taboo it's not stupid obviously I
know because it's misleading it's
deceptive is whatever but when you
actually like this is weird
and for apomorphine nature that people
have with the concept that
anthropomorphic sorry what does that
mean sorry
what does that mean academia don't worry
about huh absolute is when you humanize
something that isn't human
my goodness Azra movies when humanized
something that's not human I say no more
so um the thing is didn't below the
definition is below and morphing yeah
when you say like how when you have like
when people have pets okay that
anthropomorphizing them okay then you
give a pet name and you think it's a
person you don't obviously think it's a
person being treated so yeah people who
like the concept of lying I feel like
people humanize that way too much okay
like it's just worth taking your mom
regardless if is true or not it's just
worth at your mouth and the way the
human brain works is you hear if it's
something you hear the words you process
the words and the words will define how
you feel for that day yeah so I I don't
understand why I like sometimes the
truth just isn't the best thing for
someone in certain scenarios in certain
scenarios almost say never yeah but I'm
saying this sometimes we're just like
for example when people will say like I
don't [ __ ] know when someone says
like your mum I don't know your mom
passed away in her sleep when you really
then you find our layer like your mum
was brutally murdered by like a gang
mm-hmm like you had some level of
comfort it doesn't bring you any benefit
knowing that she got murdered by a gang
okay it makes you a lot worse
yeah but you have a better Marin you'll
talk to you for longer but the end
result is exactly the same your mum's
dead it's just whether you can deal with
it that she's such a deep example by the
way sorry cuz I don't know why I work I
don't know why we in that dark [ __ ] that
was that but yeah like it doesn't
benefit in you anywhere the only benefit
is the lie
that's the own in terms of results
that's the only benefit but if someone
actually did and you're doing that for
that person you're trying to comfort
them
yeah and as I said isn't changing
anything whether it's the truth or not
nothing changes yeah
but we've Antrim more out to humanize
this thing at that time um we've
humanized it so much yeah and pedis
toward it so much yeah
that is like no matter what this
situation that doing that thing is
unchecked unacceptable mmm telling a lie
is unacceptable who ever is if it's
beneficial or not but it's like no one
can ever tell you why yeah why because
the answer is all because it's wrong
yeah it's wrong to lie to people is
wrong to decide to place no if you when
he can give you facts like past
situation results like this is the
action this is the result this is what
you can do in between to make the result
easier or harder yeah those are the
facts
people always say nah that's wrong lying
is wrong like myself included please
like why there why is it wrong because a
lot of time there it isn't it isn't it's
the right thing to do it's still
misleading you mislead my mum thinking
mom died peacefully but it's true but it
will mislead you can mislead someone in
a million different ways I can mislead
you with my [ __ ] facial expression
right now I can say the same sentence
yeah twice now my face expression alone
will change the complete meaning of that
sentence in the words the tone the
phrasings all exactly the same just the
way I'd pull my face will deceive you
just as much as if I told you two
different sizes weights the words that
make the difference yeah when it's the
words that have the impact to make
something better or worse but deceiving
someone with words is unacceptable I
don't know one guess what I don't know I
don't know
[ __ ] me I feel like yes I'm the also if
that's what you were doing you worked
for because oh Jesus I don't know man I
was going off on one there sorry I was
lost in them I was a vixen
I was looking dead you in your eye and I
was lost in the moment is it wrong I'm
asking you
yeah sorry gee you know there are most
people just before we finish
that that right there is one of the
things I hate most so uh when I'm saying
you know what I'm saying like what why
do we do that why do we do that
that is a little bit like the thing I
hate most when people ask rhetorical
questions yeah I was in a job interview
a while back and there was a group thing
I told you about it didn't I yes a group
thing so while people off having their
individual interviews there'll be a guy
that's basically like a mic man he was
just there's like MC he was just there
to he was calm and just talked to us to
pass the time was there so many of us
that in he's gonna take hours so you
gonna be sitting you're listening to
that there was one thing from where he
was like so why he was talking about
like a smile
why does a smile have the disarming
effect that it does and then people were
like all because it like um like it's a
bright it's like relaxing something's
like you're telling me why it does but
why does it do it and he kept saying you
telling me what it does but why bro when
I said this went on for 15 minutes and
mums like guys guys you keep telling me
why is I'm asking your why and it's like
no one has the answer like just you you
know no one has the answer stop asking
us and you know we don't know yeah but
no one could say ruff we don't know that
tell us you went on for 15 minutes about
why guys but why and he knew when he
asked the question that no one knew
I hate one of my pet peeves I hate
rhetorical questions it pisses me off a
special especially rhetorical questions
when people expect an answer but they're
not actually expecting are so but when I
just said to you like like why is lying
soybean obviously you know I'm gonna
answer myself yeah and but i brough no
one knows though you know when people
are like why why but they will never say
that tell me yeah they'll be like why
don't ya why would I know I know but why
yeah brother
shut up if anyone does a [ __ ] off so
what was the answer to smarting what was
it what did the smile yeah
remember that you definitely get about I
want to know what I'm gonna be so angry
I was so invested in let you drew me in
Anita will see my next